Nhà lời mời của bộ có phòng Việt Nam, bộ có phòng cân nước, nà, Trung Quốc, lào và cán đủ chia,
đặc tử cất vàng quân nhân, sang Việt Nam, tham gia diễn biến dấu hành,
lấy cái niệm tả minam, cách mạnh tảnh tảnh tình công,
mấy chi tham tả nó một nghiên triển trăm 1 làm,
mấy chiến tham tả nó mà nghiên không trong ai làm,
và có khách nước còn hoa giá hội chủ nghĩ Việt Nam,
1 ai tảnh triển nó một nghiên triển trăm 1 làm,
1 ai tảnh triển nó mà nghiên không trong ai làm.
Sự tham xa của nguồn con nhân cân nước mặt bè trong lễ tình nghiệp là đều tự thông đẹp vì một tiêu hòa mình
hợp tác, khúng nghĩ và phát triển.
Thời sang qua, ngày thì tửi hành đổi, các đoàn đạn nỗ lực với quan những khó khăn về thời tiết,
xức áp về thời sang, xử thay đổi về bú sờ, điều kiện sinh hoa,
để nhé chống trình khá lượng tập hợp lượt, tham xa tổng duyệt trong lựa hình
các khôi sửa bình dấu hành của Việt Nam.
Cũng trong sáng nay, và đã tới tham quan trình lắm tình tử dất nước,
tảm viên năm hành trình lục lập tự sau hạnh phúc.
Đàn con nhân tất nước tham quan không sang trình bài ngoài trời của bộ của phòng,
và được giới thiệu trạng đường hào hùng hơn tảm viên năm lịch sử,
sây dự chiến đấu trường thành, những bất tiến vượt mật của quân đội như rất địa Nam.
Bàn con nhân tất nước, được nhân xanh tham xa trình lắm cho đó nông nhật.
Nên là si, để bạn đã có tế, tìm hiểu việc trạng đường lịch sử về phán của sân tổ Việt Nam,
cảm nhận được lòng yêu nước, niềm tự hào sân tổng, và tình thần hiểu khác của mỗi người sân Việt Nam.